[Music]
good evening i'm trey gowdy and it's
sunday night in america
thank you for joining us have you ever
wondered why we have government in the
first place
have you ever wondered why we consented
to be governed why we
gathered ourselves together as a people
and subjected ourselves to this thing
called
law whether it's the local state or
federal level there has to be
a purpose a reason for joining hands
and forming this thing called government
and then allowing that government to
pass and enforce
laws which can incent and prevent
individual acts and decisions we are
after all
a nation of laws and not a nation of men
and women as john adams famously said
and even as i posed that question i am
sure there are words and phrases going
through your mind
you may believe education is the primary
function or responsibility of government
especially at the state and local level
perhaps you believe it is regulating
commerce or providing for our common
national defense
perhaps you believe the purpose of
government is to safeguard your natural
rights
perhaps you believe it is to provide a
common currency or
build and maintain our roads and bridges
and airports
when you look at government across all
three levels
local state and federal all of those
answers are correct
but i would list something else first i
would
start with something else
i would list public safety number one
public safety is the preeminent function
of government that's what i believe
but it's not just me if you look at the
very beginning
the preamble to our u.s constitution you
will see this
we the people of the united states in
order to form a more
perfect union establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility provide for
the common defense
promote the general welfare every one of
those phrases
has something to do with public safety
with law and order with protection
so when i see spikes in crime i view it
as both
proof of why we have government in the
first place
which is because everyone cannot be
counted on to treat their fellow
citizens with respect and dignity
and i also view rising crime rates
as a failure of government to meet its
number one priority
and i don't care if it's a republican or
a democrat or any other party
politics is of very little significance
if you're dead injured robbed or
assaulted
i never had a political conversation
with a crime victim or a cop
or a fellow prosecutor never public
safety is too important
to be just another political tool
but unfortunately everyone does not see
it that way
we heard these ridiculous calls to
defund the police
we heard even more ridiculous calls to
eliminate the police
what we need they claimed was really
more social workers and psychologists
you let me know if that is the first
thing you think
of when you are being assaulted on a
subway or you
hear someone breaking into your house or
god forbid someone pulls a weapon on you
you let me know whether you want to call
social workers
and psychologists or call the police
and it wasn't just the crazy calls for
doing away with the police
there are also these so-called
progressive prosecutors who have taken
over
some district attorney offices
throughout the country
these so-called progressive prosecutors
can't find a single solitary person they
think should actually be in prison
if you want to spend your career keeping
guilty people
out of prison you should be a defense
attorney
not a prosecutor and we had the media
excusing acts of violence calling them
simply
protests and even one media personality
asking
what may be the single dumbest question
i have ever heard ask
which is quote show me where it says
protesters are supposed to be peaceful
okay i will it's called the law it's
called the criminal code
it actually lets you know you cannot
steal
people's things because you are mad it
actually lets you know
you cannot set things on fire because
you perceive
some injustice it actually lets you know
you cannot
injure a cop because some other cop did
not meet your expectations
the law actually helps us understand the
difference
between an arsonist and a protester
and both sides have shown a willingness
to engage in this relativism
excusing their own supporters for acts
of lawlessness but i do not
anyone can follow a law they agree with
anyone can act responsibly when things
are going their way
the true test of citizenship is can you
follow a law you disagree with
can you act responsibly when you are
disappointed
either we are a nation of laws or we are
not
and when i reflect on the rising
homicide or murder rates
i think of all the promise and potential
this country
offers and then i wonder of all these
freedoms and liberties we enjoy
how many of them are of any use
when you are dead freedom of speech
free exercise of religion the right to
counsel
what use is any of that
if you are dead so you can put me down
as someone who believes public safety is
the primary function of government
and when crime begins to soar and there
are more and more
innocent victims you can put me down as
wondering
what is the use of government if it
can't do the main thing we need it to do
which is to keep us safe hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else